Hi, Dr. Cotters. My husband has had two stints put in his heart three months ago.
He's still experiencing some issues when physically exerting himself, such as walking uphill
or running with, he's had burping, starting, chest pain, left arm hurting. His cardio doctor
doesn't feel it's heart related. As he also does have digestive disorders, but my husband
is still concerned, mainly feeling that it could be the heart, any thoughts? Well, of course
it could be the heart. So what do you do to find out if it's a heart? Well, getting
some standard blood testing would be helpful. So getting a good cardio lipid panel would
be helpful. Certainly, so understand that the same nerves that go to the heart that
could give you these symptoms, your doctor is correct that digestive issues, especially stomach
related digestive issues, the upper GI issues, because they follow the same neurological
pathway can give you the exact same symptoms. Matter of fact, people with indigestion, people
with heightal hernia issues can get what's called when it's been termed as pseudocoronaries,
because they can actually feel like an elephant, stand up or chest, they feel like they're
having a heart attack. They go in, they run at LVH, that's negative, they run some other
blood panels that show possibility of acute myocardial infarction. They're all negative.
They do an EKG and it's all normal. And then they, you know, everything has passed and
they, you know, they call it a pseudo-corporate, and they suggest you go to a GI doctor, which
typically does you very little good, because they'll put you on something even horrific, more
horrific called prilosec, which is a PBI that blocks all your stomach acid. The problem
really is a deficiency in stomach acid. So highly suggest you go to our website, cuttersclinic.com
and search in the blog. So we have well over 1,000 blog posts, many of them tied to different
videos, explaining the condition in, you know, ad nausea. And I think one thing that would
help you is to go to our blog and search hypochloridria hypochloridria, if you're just typing
that, it will probably come up. I have a real nice search on our website. Hypochloridria
means decrease in stomach acid. Chloridria stands for chloride. It's HCl is the stomach acid.
These little cells in your stomach call prinal cells make. And when we eat, you know,
emptims, colorings, flavorings, glyphosate, you know, chemicals, we damage those cells
and they don't produce enough HCl. And when we don't produce enough HCl, we don't get proper
digestion of food. Food goes into the smell and tested. As a bolus, that's only partially
digested. It puts a whole lot of stress on our pancreas. It increases the risk of pancreatic
inflammation in or pancreatic cancers. It puts a lot of stress on our liver and our bile duct,
our bile system, which creates digestive enzymes for lipids. And it really stems from a decrease
stomach acid. So hypochloridria will cause the food to sit in your stomach longer than it should
because it's not being digested. The little stomach acids you have can burgeon up into your
esophagus. You can burp it up and you have acid in the use. They go, I have too much stomach acid.
You go on a PPI or go take tubs or roleaches or something like that. You're actually causing
worse problems. And so I would agree with the doctor that you should, you know, investigate
that, you know, first. I mean, you could know fairly quickly if you start taking HCl, if you go to
that blog post. And I have a blog post on helicobacter pylori because having chronic HCl deficiency
is going to set a person up for Hpylori infections. And so I have a blog post on that as well that
you should probably read too. So it's kind of a simple fix in the sense of what you need to do is start
taking HCl and digestive enzymes with your meals. However, if you already have it also because of a
decreased stomach acid, yes, you get it also because of a decreased stomach acid because a decreased
stomach acid allows the continued growth of the opportunistic organism that's called helicobacter pylori.
And that's what causes a stomach ulcer. So that stomach ulcer will then be irritated by the HCl.
So your fatigue HCl and it's like, oh my gosh, I really hurt my stomach. You need to back off and try
to heal the stomach with a decrease or a decrease or some other things to help heal your stomach
lighting. And then in a couple of weeks, go back on the HCl or just try apple cider vinegar for a while
which is a little bit milder acid. And then get on the HCl. So there's a process. So I lay it out in
that blog post. So I lay out the whole way to start that process and to take care of that problem in
that blog post and to deal with Hpylori as well. So yeah, you do want to get your heart checked. Yes,
absolutely. But you do want to get your digestive system corrected because you talk about cord area
issues in Hpylori. Hpylori is one of the top four causes of coronary, artery disease. So yes,
Hpylori goes beyond the stomach, goes the stomach and causes inflammation and damage to the endothelial
cells. Those are the cells that line the arteries. And it could get underneath the endothelial
lining in the heart and damage the smooth muscle cells, damage the receptor sites, the ACE receptors
and other receptors cause blood pressure issues, cause inflammation in the endothelial
lining and cause heart disease. So dealing with so many things stem from this from digestion stem from
the stomach. So that's really where you need to start. So you know, you have, oh, I have a serious
disease. I have cancer when you should still start healing the gut. I have serious disease. I have
heart disease. Well, you still should start dealing, you know, heal the gut not that you don't deal with
as other things, but you got to heal the gut as well. Okay, so again, go to cuttersclinic.com,
search hypochloridria, search helico-bacter pylori or Hpylori. And you'll find that those
long posts that go into that, what I'm just saying, in detail, and I know they have some videos on them too.